voix incroyable vous êtes ravissante
voilà c'est bon chez eux et merci d'être
là alors cette histoire elle va faire
énormément parler parce que c'est vrai
que le montage fait par la production
lors de cette émission est un petit peu
curieux sur ses dires vous allez voir on
vous a fait une compile de la
présentation de tous les candidats
regardez les autres candidats regardez
avant de chanter regardez ce qui se
passe pour regarder vous qu'est ce que
tu as préparé comme chanson j'ai choisi
une oeuvre à neuf la chanson du film the
greatest showman l histoire du film
aussi ses licences est qu'il est très
connu dans son pays
elle va chanter dans une autre personne
inconnue
je choisis ne me jugez pas de camille
lellouche ça parle des failles des gens
et du coup c'est comme un espèce de cris
de désespoir naturopole de match il a
choisi porte à poser il ya des paroles à
l'intérieur qui me font penser à mon
beau père qui est décédé alors vous
venez voir la présentation de certains
candidats vous allez voir dans l'instant
la présentation de stylia voulait le
garder des gens qui étaient avant que je
remonte aux téléspectateurs voulait voir
présentation de c'est à dire c'est pas
le même délire oui non il ya une vraie
volonté de discrimination et on y
reviendra au moment du choix de la
chanson peut-être mais il ya eu une
organisation fait pour vous éliminer et
elle n'est pas à mon avis étrangères à
votre couleur de peau vous verrez la
production la production
ça ne peut pas vaine ça oui la
production hélas n'avais pas envie que
vous alliez très loin et la maison de
disques a choisi coulures gilles lamy je
vous le dire on veut porter son nom de
son chapeau bas parce que ils ont ils
ont non mais je ils ont parce que c'est
extrêmement grave c'est finalement j'ai
une blessure et que moi je le comprends
pas ils ont tout fait pour que vous
chantiez cette chanson normalement ce
sont les candidats qui ont le droit de
choisir et vous et vous ont proposé deux
chansons ils ne nous ont pas laissés
totalement choisir et dans les deux
chansons il vous en orientée vers celle
là et pourquoi selon mes informations je
sais même pas si vous le savez
parce qu'elle ne correspond pas
totalement à votre timbre de voix parce
qu'elle a été chantée rechanter et parce
qu'ils savaient que ce serait plus
facile de vous éliminer si ça c'est pas
de la discrimination chez quoi alors
voilà alors je vais vous montrer
regardez on a vu on a vu ce qui se passe
pour la présentation des veaux bendella
il explique pourquoi il chante telle ou
telle chanson vous regardez votre
présentation
la seule chose qu'on a pu voir avant
votre passage c'est vous en coulisse
regarde des chansons en partant talent
vous le savez c'est un dommage à un
amour perdu qu'est cet artiste
l'assurance et et l'émotion vous pouvez
vous en douter
on devrait être intense
mae
beaucoup
[Musique]
sem
c'est à dire je vous je me sens très
très très ému quand vous voyez ces
images oui beaucoup
et parce que je revois lors des
tournages
tout ce qui a pu se passer et j'ai
vraiment à cette aventure complètement
oui en plus moi quand je suis arrivé là
bas j'étais heureuse surtout de pouvoir
être coaché parce que moi j'ai appris
dans le tas en tout cas en ce qui
concerne la musique parce que moi j'ai
fait des études plutôt d'économie et de
sociologie de sciences politiques la
raison et puis comme j'ai toujours
baigné dans la musique le destin en qui
je crois a permis que finalement je
fasse de ça moi aussi
et donc c'est vrai que oui je
il y avait beaucoup de j'étais motivé
vraiment en tout cas pas mourir
l'émission giro il convient de sur la
chanson est ce que c'est une chanson que
vous avez choisi je dois bien content au
début j'avais choisi de chanter lily de
pierre perret pourquoi alors cette
chanson magnifique non c'est une chanson
qui m'accompagne depuis que je suis
arrivé en france avec ma famille en 2004
mon chef de choeur de la chorale du
collège j'avais donné cette chanson
alors jusqu'ici j'avais bien évidemment
compris le texte
je trouvais le forme complètement et je
ne savais pas que des années après en
tout cas j'allais vivre même la chanson
alors dans mon histoire personnelle
alors vous proposer cette chanson la
production et vous dise quoi exactement
donc avec la production on discute un
c'est vraiment une décision qui est fait
est là il est vrai que le constat est
fait même par moi-même que peut-être que
lily de pierre perret vocalement parlant
ça c'est pas si c'est vrai c'est vrai
parce que la chanson chanson magnifique
c'est le truc que je débarque en fait
dans une nouvelle team celle de florent
pagny que moi j'appelle la team des
grandes voix sur ce ça j'ai eu
l'occasion d'être dans cette salle a été
repêché déjà éjectable et donc j'ai eu
l'occasion de voir un petit peu tous les
talents et de me rendre compte que
peut-être que lille est effectivement ce
qui me font comprendre et je réagis pas
ça ça j'appelle mon père j'ai le temps
d'appeler mon père je dis papa bon j'ai
choisi quoi lilly who and will always
love you on part avec cce qui vous ont
proposé les deux pieds tout c'est vous
il faut savoir aussi que à huile en
baisse de 8 et d'un mâle liste d'accords
voilà donc en fait toujours une liste
d'une vingtaine jay et vous avez une
explication pour vous avez choisi c'est
sur wii j'ai expliqué c'était quoi
l'explication
alors parce que c'est ça qui va choisir
cette chanson parce qu'elle la lie
elle allie à la fois vous disais quoi a
été coupée au montage vous l'avez dit ça
oui ça vous allez nous dire ce soir
c'est aller couper au montage exact vous
avez donc on voit on voit que les autres
explique pourquoi ils ont choisi telle
ou telle chanson vous avez fait
l'explication dans the voice donc qui
devait passer sur tf1 samedi soir ça a
été coupée au montage d'explication
l'explication était là qu'elle essaie ça
a été la plus impactée le plus important
pour moi c'était
ce message la dernière fois que je
chante a eu loris love you je suis sur
une scène toulousaine et il ya la maman
de l'homme que j'aimais à l'époque qui
est là qui était le seul soutien
d'ailleurs véritable d'un cru dans cette
affaire et je dédie cette chanson à cet
homme c'est un amour impossible dû au
fait de nos différences de couleur de
peau clairement pourquoi va écouter que
vous dire j'ai découvert en tout ça en
tout cas cette réalité malheureuse qui
détruit des vies qui brisent vraiment et
donc quand je chante i'm always love you
je me souviens de ça on me voit
d'ailleurs assez ému je ne suis
d'ailleurs pas satisfaite de ma
prestation parce que je vais beaucoup
mieux chanter d'ailleurs quand je lui
adresse la lui avait adressé à l'époque
et là je suis prise d'émotion on ne voit
pas ta la fin je pleure mais je pleure
littéralement le public scander mon nom
parce que comprend le pourquoi quand
j'explique le pourquoi de cette chanson
et tout ça ça a été coupée je me suis
senti un peu j'avais déjà vécu une
injustice et là rebelote c'est comme si
c'est une injustice sur une injustice
qui malgré ma génération opposé célia si
il y avait vraiment la discrimination
dans the voice pourquoi où vous aurez
repêché parce que à la limite vous avez
été sortis se serait dit bon ben on
attend ça va bien on invite je vous le
dis je vois là s'il y avait des
discriminations puisqu'il vous avait
sorti pourquoi ils ont laissé florent
pagny vous repêchés la production aurait
très bien pu dire à florent pagny non
non tu repêche quelqu'un d'autre c'est
ça que je me pose comme question
je ne parlerai pas vraiment merci
monsieur gilles verdez revente de ce
soutien mais je ne parlerais pas
vraiment de discrimination je pense que
c'est un choix éditorial après mais il
est vrai que le constat est là que je
suis la seule à pour qui on ne montre ni
les répétitions not pourquoi de ma
chanson alors que là c'est vrai que là
au delà vraiment
de fait de chanter moi j'ai un message
bien pas comme ça c'est vrai voilà et
c'est ça je ne prenais pas passer voilà
c'est un certain poids de la production
non parce que je suis assez d'accord
c'est un peu curieux que tous les autres
et les coulisses que tous les autres et
pourquoi ils ont choisi telle ou telle
chanson donc la raison et elle note
guillaume genton sans dire que the voice
est raciste parce que je pense que ce
n'est pas le cas alors il est vrai que
c'est des émissions extrêmement charte
et il ya des magnétos avant les passages
qui sont extrêmement charte et et on
voit bien qu avant chaque prestation
vous avez l'explication du candidat donc
si l'on coupe est votre explication qui
en l'occurrence et est une ode aux
confins contre le racisme en fait
pourquoi ils l'ont fait c'est ça la
vraie question
donc on ne peut pas alors moi je vous
dire moi je peux pas entendre sur ce
plateau de the voice est raciste
alors ça ne s'est jamais vu dans the
void ça c'est vraiment ça c'est vraiment
aimé ça c'est inadmissible gilles même
si je vous aime beaucoup la vous avez là
vous avez dit n'a pensé c'était moi de
vous dire ça arrive alors dans ce cas là
alors noste fayard yeux andrew chin
je suis désolé mais la fille de
l'animateur mais là il a dit n'importe
quoi il est lassé c'est pas grave je
pense pas que sur un design kent
mais bon y'a juste on se pose la
question mais je pense pas que c'est pas
on n'a pas dit que c'était du racisme
on pense que voilà je pense que dans ces
émissions là et benjamin castaldi ne va
pas me dire le contraire
on essaie de mettre en avant tel ou tel
candidat peut-être que c'était bien et
même elle le dit c'est pas une question
de racisme elle le dit elle même c'est
bien c'est juste ils ont mis en avant
plus des candidats que d'autres assez
bien c'est très bruyant là c'est très
classe et voilà c'est prêt ils sont pris
à mon labo laquelle on la voit même pas
en coulisses on ne voit pas avec son
coach ouais c'est plus que why enchérir
ça c'est sûr bah oui les jours a dit il
ya deux choses d'abord je crois pas du
tout que ce soit raciste parce
qu'effectivement convié chanter freedom
convoi le dis encore dans l'époque de
vienne et avec 26,1 justement c'est une
chanson magnifique une sorte de hoda
black like that her chanté par beyoncé
et donc je pense qu'il ya aucune
ambiguïté là dessus
après effectivement au niveau de la
ligne éditoriale moi je comprends votre
frustration il paraît que votre opus
votre message était plein de tolérance
plein de bienveillance et un message
très touchant c'est vrai nous le verset
les coachs effectivement je ne comprends
pas alors il vaut petite pancarte souple
et bernard montiel
non non non non
nicolas pernikoff fou qui connaissait
bien mais non je n'y crois pas du tout
une histoire de racisme géant mais ça
c'est non ça c'est ça vaut pour vous
avez eu l'honnêteté moi je regarde de
voice tout le temps vous avez
l'honnêteté de reconnaître que vous
allez chanter faux et je suis désolé
vous avait du charisme
vous avez une super voix la chanson je
suis pas sûr que ce soit le bon choix de
chanson c'est c'est pas ça comment
expliquer que à un moment donné vous
voyez bien que chaque fois qu'on parle
des candidats c'est le beau père qui est
mort c'est la mère qui suit ce oui mais
c'est un mais c'est un autre mais un
nouveau style de jeu à mon avis à mon
avis je pense qu'ils sont voilà la
compétition avant je pense qu'ils
avaient envie d'avoir des messages
qu'ils soient un peu mièvre mièvre et
brad engagement faire un spectacle
plutôt plat plutôt lisse un peu la tête
si je conçois voilà ils sont dit voilà
on va pas remettre encore une couche on
adhère ou là on l'a laissé vont la
laisser faire entre guillemets quand
elle est arrivée dans le show il
ils vont faire un geste oui mais très
maladroit parce que pour le coup c'est
encore pire maintenant voilà bien sûr
que oui
vous avez été déçu d'avoir été coupé au
montage surtout votre message qui est
important oui ce message là oui et je
n'ai pas une fois de plus la justice en
fait sur cette histoire j'ai envie de
dire et surtout ce message comme l'avait
dit vraiment de tolérance qu'on est tous
en et des hommes tous part et ceux de
messages que j'ai délivrés mais je
crains pas c'est à dire dans votre
portrait vous alliez délivrer ce message
ils ont gardé dans le temps venu pour
tromper la wii dont il avait gagné mais
bon voilà
mais ils oublient effectivement et moi
que je revis à will always love you
réalisé un monsieur nicolas jeu
je chante faux parce que je suis au bord
des larmes cette chanson je l'ait déjà
chanté ou verrez des vidéos traîner
certainement sur internet et mais je
suis au bord de la mais je suis en train
de me dire stellia contient toi parce
que tu dois chanter j'ai venu c'est un
concours de chant donc on va pas pleurer
parce que mais quand même voilà je me
suis dit tu vas chanter ça et tu vas
pouvoir délivrer son message bien
particulier et qu'enfin on puisse avoir
le droit d'aimer en fait simplement qui
ont fait notre couleur de tes bien et ça
vous en voulez à la production je n'irai
pas jusque là je n'y arrive pas et cela
parce que pendant tout ce que j'ai vécu
pendant l'émission on a vraiment été
chouchoutés je remercie les co coach
qu'on ne voit pas forcément la télé j'ai
eu messieurs damien silvert angie aussi
je les remercie parce que vraiment angie
a su mon histoire c'est à dire que
lorsque j'arrivais que je rencontre
cette femme pour la première fois la
pauvre et s'est dit mais quel est ce
phénomène
parce que j'arrivais vraiment à pas
lourd et je rentre dans la salle je
pleure voilà et je lui explique qu elle
me calme
elle prend le temps donc la production
vous leur diriez quoi soit merci il ya
le in et le merci de m'avoir fait vivre
cette expérience
mais en fait j'aimerais voir pourquoi on
n'a pas montré sa vous avez envie
d'avoir des réponses mais non quoi bon
et bien on aimerait bien que la
production nous répondent d'ailleurs
pourquoi on n'a pas eu votre votre
message et pourquoi on ne vous a pas vu
dans les coups il a c'est un homme comme
les autres candidats puisque ni la seule
ni guillaume pour finir après il ya une
autre hypothèse c'est que dans ce deuil
c'est le public qui choisit le gagnant
mais la production aussi elle choisira
gagnant avant l'émission elle a envie de
faire gagner quelqu'un donc elle choisi
de mettre en avant certains candidats
pour créer l'attachement de raconter des
histoires plus forte et peut-être qu'ils
n'avaient pas vu en vous une gagnante à
tort sans doute parce que vous étiez
extrêmement populaire et donc ils se
sont dit on va faire plus court on va
pas créer la tâche moteur parce qu on
enregistre malgré tout par à côté à côté
en tout cas on merci célia d'avoir été
avec nous merci à vous venez chanter
avec nous quand vous voulez
c'est d'avoir été là